hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es ein kleines video
tutorial zum thema modellieren und zwar
werde ich diese süßen babyschuhe
modellieren
die sind aus modelliermasse gemacht also
aus von dort und blüten pasta gemischt
und ich werde euch jetzt einfach schritt
für schritt zeigen wie sie funktionieren
und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal
direkt die zutaten was wir dafür
benötigen und dann geht's auch direkt
los
ich brauch jetzt dafür etwas kokosfett
dann nämlich palmen etwas blüten passte
hier habe ich bereits von der mit blüten
passte verknetet und zwar im verhältnis
eins zu eins das heißt immer ein teil
von land und ein teil blüten passte und
ich habe mir cd farben grün hellblau
pink gelb und eben weiß ausgesucht dann
könnt ihr die farben immer auch gerne
variieren indem ihr einfach etwas
lebensmittel verpasste mit dazu gibt es
braucht dann noch etwas zucker kleber
becker stärker zum ausrollen und hier
habe ich bereits meine schablonen und
zwar habe ich dir jetzt auch schon
ausgeschnitten die findet ihr auch auf
meinem blog da können diese ausdrucken
und ausschneiden und zur hilfe habe ich
mir cd farben drauf geschrieben weil ich
jetzt nämlich einen ganz kunden zu
machen möchte
jetzt legen wir auch direkt los zuerst
nämlich jetzt die weiße mutter die masse
und troll sie für die sole etwa 3 mm
dünn aus und das mache ich jetzt hier
mit diesen zwei hölzern
am besten geht es auch auf etwas becker
stärke
dann lege ich jetzt hier die sohle drauf
und schnaitsee aber mit diesem
schneidewerkzeug aus
jetzt riecht die sohle um denn ich
möchte zwei verschiedene schuhe einmal
rechts einmal links und schneidet jetzt
auch noch mal aus
und jetzt muss ich die shows sollen erst
mal über nacht trocknen lassen
die sohlen dürfen jetzt eine nacht
trocknen sie sind jetzt richtig hart und
jetzt kann es direkt mit dem show
weitergehen und es ist übrigens ziemlich
sinnvoll dass ihr immer mit beiden schon
parallel arbeitet dann habt ihr das
alles in allem durch ganz fertig und
können dann direkt immer weitermachen
jetzt nehme ich meine pinkfarbene
modelliermasse und rollte jetzt 2 mm
dünn aus das mache ich jetzt zuerst
nicht entstehen und dann rolle ich eben
noch im kleinen ein bisschen dünner
jetzt bestreitet die oberfläche so ein
bisschen mit palmen damit die schablone
etwas drauf habt mich läuft
jetzt nehme ich mir das zweite stück
also hier die zweite schablone und kann
sie jetzt auch zweimal ausschneiden
und jetzt nehme ich mir hier so
einprägte werkzeug und präg hier die
naht ein
die
mit einer 6 mm spritzte stehe ich jetzt
hier jeweils drei löcher 1
da kommen dann später die schnürsenkel
durch
die teile lege ich mir zur seite und
habe jetzt hier schon mal blaue
ausgerollt und damit schneide ich jetzt
die schablone nummer drei aus
die zwei teile auch ausgeschnitten und
jetzt kann ich direkt hier beim schuh
weitermachen ausgeschnitten und zwar
brauche ich jetzt etwas vom zucker
kleber und den streiche ich jetzt hier
am rand entlang
dann bereite ich hier schon mal zwei
kugeln vor und zwar setze ich die jetzt
nämlich hier ein damit ich einfach so
ein puffer habe wo daneben der schule
eine halterung hat und so ein bisschen
halt hat den klebe ich da vorne rein
schön abrunden
und jetzt gebe ich mit ich hinten den
teil nummer zwei an den pinkfarbenen
m
und vorne kommt dann der blaue teilt
haben also schablone nummer drei
jetzt müssten nur noch mal die ränder
von schablonen nummer zwei abnehmen und
das dann darunter verstecken
und damit diese lasche jetzt nicht hier
hinten runter klappt stofftier da
einfach so ein bisschen papier ein so
ein bisschen küchenpapier
und dann kann es damit trocknen
und die restlichen schablonen schneide
ich jetzt aus dem im übrigen weiß aus
den weißen halbrunden teils leben wir
jetzt da vorne an und zwar mit der
geraden seite nach oben und die runde
seite wird unten fest gedrückt
das kleine stück hier habe ich jetzt
auch noch geprägt und da kommt jetzt
auch etwas käfer dran auf die rückseite
der obere teil wird jetzt so etwa 1 cm
runter geklickt und wird direkt hier
hinten angesehen
und jetzt lebe ich noch dieses band hier
einmal außen rum hinten mit ich anfangen
die
jetzt möchte ich als nächstes die
schnürsenkel machen und dafür nehme ich
meine von dort modell ihr presse und
setzt da eine scheibe rein da kann ich
nämlich verschiedene stränge
herauspressen
und da nehme ich jetzt diese kleine loch
schüler da will ich jetzt hinten etwas
gelb ein
dann wird es verschraubt
und durch die drehbewegung kommt dann
vorne dieser kordel raus
und damit es einfacher geht befestige
ich hier ihnen jetzt mal eine kleine
korte
jetzt kommt immer überall wo die kordel
mit dem schulen verbindung kommt einfach
ein bisschen kleber drin
jetzt arbeite ich mit zwei kordeln
weiter und schnürte den schuh
und dann könnt ihr die enden abschneiden
so lange sie haben wollt und formt sie
unten einfach
jetzt gebe ich hier noch einen kleinen
dünnen grünstrand
und so ist jetzt die schuhe noch mal
komplett eine nacht trocknen lassen
die babyschuhe sind jetzt getrocknet ich
habe es nämlich eine nacht einfach auf
dem schrank stehen lassen damit keiner
dran kommt und so sehen sie jetzt fertig
aus es sind auch richtig hart ich kann
sie mit den schnüren hier zusammen
bewegen ohne dass sie kaputt gehen aber
natürlich muss man trotzdem vorsichtig
sein denn es ist ja trotzdem aus zucker
und sehr zerbrechlich das heißt am
besten nicht verlassen und ich werde
jetzt gleich auf eine torte setzen werde
nicht damit fertig dekorieren ich freue
mich schon auf eure babyschuhe wenn ihr
die man nach macht und mir dann einfach
fotos auf instagram und auf facebook
schickt und ich hoffe das video hatte
ich ganz viel spaß gemacht wie gesagt
gibt es dann dieses schnittmuster also
die schablonen einfach auf meinem blog
zum herunterladen
da können diese dann ausdrucken und zum
beispiel auch größer oder kleiner
kopieren und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen und wir sehen uns
das nächste mal wieder fest an